you
everyone is cherrymon just calm and I
just got paired up playing aids-free Oh
game so we are not gonna play perfect
chess 300 you need to get a move on and
fast I like going with this h3 move
before applying d4 maybe even rook to e1
let's do rook e1 first and we're gonna
do this I want them to commit they're
deep on first before I play d4 or maybe
decide to give my bishop a kick so let's
see I rarely play three oh I don't see
why I can't do that there isn't any
tactic on e4 there isn't a good
discovery as far as I could tell we're
gonna find out though I guess huh then
the rook here I just back up with my
queen this is a long-term issue if there
isn't something quick this is something
I could bite out this isolated pawn so
rook here
okay there's queen there huh oh that's a
sharp move hitting my rook and Bishop
Knight c3 Knight takes pawn
I have a little bit this is a critical
moment here let's go for it
they might they might go for this here
I'm gonna see they'd be given up a very
valuable piece okay pawn takes what's
wrong with pawn takes let's see it and
see what they do okay
well now they're ready to move the
knight I should probably just get out of
the line of fire recapture at the bishop
down about ten seconds
yeah if pre move on and there are
multiple Primo's let's not forget that
Queen b6 I have Bishop e3 okay I'm up
upon keep this night under control maybe
pin the night rook here
Knight here what I really want to give
up my Bishop Bishop g5 h6 Bishop takes
Knight Bishop takes and then rook here
they have the two bishops but I'm up
upon something better than Bishop g5 I'm
gonna go for it I'm gonna go with h6
let's just take and hang on to my pawn I
can that didn't last long
okay well I'm gonna give that pawn back
up and then look to get to the seventh
rank I'm gonna take that okay they're
smart they're maybe I could do this
actually
I'm Bishop g5 maybe I go back here hmm
alrighty let me just go back a step
maybe I do this yeah this move actually
will kick the Bishop to d7 let's see
you even consider pushing let's not
forget about that weakening my dark
squares over here let's just step up
again you can come back over maybe I do
this hmm this looks interesting pressure
on f7 hitting the Bishop d6 d6 y sd6
Knight d5 opens up a new square for my
piece even on time where are they gonna
go with the bishop let's just push here
bishop here I could take and push
further he has passed what are they
doing about f7 f6 looks ugly that also
looks pretty pretty ugly too how about
we go here take and then Bishop here I'm
hitting the b7 pawn let's take actually
bishop takes like a push there in a pin
I could do this though no I'm on this I
might have just blundered Bishop takes
Knight Bishop takes here might be
working out hmm that's a good move umm
don't know what to do got a move though
Knight to d5 and then here that was
probably better did I lose my chance to
do that Bishop b3 95 97 even on time
again let's try that there Bishop cannot
move yeah I want it pile up on this even
see 795 Knight c7 I have a time edge
let's go there tonight here also there's
Knight g6 Knight here threatening the
rook and threatening a fork pretty
serious
let's just go right in there they're
probably sack also they can't move their
king
okay how about we trade rooks I almost
missed that they should do it I'm gonna
grab that pawn centralize my king oh
they just dropped their Bishop it's
gonna be it I'm ahead on time now
they're gonna play this one out get some
free moves in there huh oh man we're
gonna see if something was missed right
there in that middle game alright they
resigned let me I don't know that how
much there is to really review with this
one this opening yeah there's something
with this I like seeing this deep on
move he's how to say it Black is
currently after their castles move
they're in a position where they will
next need to open a door for the light
square Bishop so d6 or d5 if they play
d5 before I commit my deep on what this
means is that I could play e5 let me
just put it on the board actually let me
point it out here it's my move in the
game I played h3 but if I play d4 right
now this is how black can follow up they
could take and then immediately
challenge my structure in the center my
pawn duo in the center and if I play
here they could centralize the knight
this is something I want to avoid I
don't want to allow this possibility for
black to post up in the center on e4 so
by delaying my D pawns advance by
playing h3 first now if black let's say
plays d5 without me for
playing d4 I could play e5 and this
isn't a possibility because I could play
d3 and guess who's trapped so I like
this h3 move it's useful more long-term
flight square and it's kind of a waiting
move let's see how let's see what black
does with their D pawn or if they'll
even touch the D pawn in the game they
play d5 and then it allows I believe at
least this d4 move as scared it is scary
and I'm going to check it out with
stockfish maybe there is some trick that
they have against my queen I'm thinking
that there might be some tactic with how
they played at Queen a5 but then on the
next move Knight takes e4 with Bishop
takes pawn and then taking the bishop
I'll investigate that but yeah this was
my idea behind h3 I know it was really
quick with this three Oh game couldn't
really voice all the thoughts that were
running through my mind but I certainly
wanted to share that with you right now
my idea of what's playing h3 prior to d4
I want to see this D pawn commit I want
some more information with Blacks next
move before I pulled the trigger on my D
pawn so how did this play out played in
the center yeah it's a big moment now
maybe maybe I just got nothing at all
what about d5 I was talking about this
is a target well what if he's no longer
on board I guess I have this if I'm just
capturing I have absolutely nothing take
stick takes takes and now it's black
who's even better one move away from
completing the development if for me
it's quite tricky to even get to this
natural c3 square
so imagine on d5 I would have to try e5
and yeah okay I think that's that's what
would be called for if black is to play
d5 where the knight go you know this
phone is a bit cramping
not here I could challenge him right
away
Knight takes Queen takes pawn takes
mm-hmm I guess the Queen and then maybe
try to get in a quick Bishop III to d4
you know maybe a slight pull here for
black this guy is passed so I'd want to
block hate him as soon as possible okay
played it out here we're late d5 after
Queen a5 which was really aggressive
hitting up both bishop and rook now d5
you see right here I was thinking they
could take down Queen takes Knight
Bishop takes here pawn takes Queen here
ah this is something to avoid dark
square weaknesses but it's more than
that this rook actually just cannot even
move rook here got mate coming up next
yeah so this is this is probably
something they looked at and then shied
away from seeing that this combination
is involving the loss of their most
important piece without question
they're dark square bishop if he's not
around and I still have I'm I still have
my dark square bishop yeah that's gonna
be a problem for black so this is a
reason not to go in for this even though
it appears to win back the pawn it is
giving up a super valuable piece you
know this is just losing here for black
they're underdeveloped and they're
losing the exchange because of the
mention rook d8 queen e8 leading to mate
so I guess I am able to hang on to this
pond
well no excuse me I'm not uh pipe on
here but they don't have this tactic on
e4 is what I mean and they're in a tough
spot then if they're not able to exploit
my Queens position
Queens are off I'm giving up the bishop
pair with Bishop g5 did I have something
better right around here I'm not so sure
it felt weird to do this because it
allows 94 and takes takes and how am i
developing with this bishops diagonal
open can't even play quiet move like
rook to be won to defend and then move
the bishop because it's covered so it's
quite tricky to even a complete
development if I'm doing something like
this defending this pawn directly with
the rook however why wasn't I
considering this move don't have a good
answer to that that's probably better
yeah the bishop he doesn't need to stay
on this dog and I should have played
Bishop b3 preserved my bishops yeah
preserve my dark square bishop and then
just go from there
I imagine Bishop before rook a to d1 and
I'm up a clean pawn I could even
consider once I have this a little bit
more development in with Bishop f4 I
could consider getting to the seventh
rank and then who knows maybe targeting
f7 with the Bishop and rook okay and you
know there was probably some tactics mr.
Wright around here something I could
have done better but yeah at this point
I must be the better side being up upon
but let's see what stockfish has to say
about this one and what more we can take
away from it so give me a minute and
I'll bring it up okay stockfish let's
see where we can improve where is there
a shift kind of want to get right into
this middle game where it is suggesting
d3 not d4 is there really an issue with
d4 no takes takes takes again I think
takes wants to play takes d4 I thought
it said d5 for a second but okay let's
go with what was played in the game and
what's being called for right now it
takes
he takes he takes right away I have this
idea of a 595 ok they went with the
night on Queen takes so this is fine
this is uh there isn't any great tactic
for black here computer suggests a six
fish of a four and then D six and I'm
happy with this straightforward play
perfect square for the night
imagine a bishop playing to this nice
square F for because it eyes up is soft
point D six rook a to D one White has
very nice play okay well very nice play
I don't know if that's the best way to
say it but certainly comfortable to
deploy the pieces in its black who's
working with the structural defect so on
Queen a five-night c3 and now it wants
to go with the d6 odd move just allows
me to grab the pawn but wants to get
some development in so black is
struggling here actually Knight c3
let's do meet this d5 move with did pop
up be five but capturing is fine and
that's what I went with
I should oh yeah Queen a4 suggested
that's what I did
just want the Queen's off cuz now now
this is serious this is this is the
first moment where the knight is ready
to play in the center and not you know
it can't be captured now it has the
support of the bishop so if I'm making a
passing move this is a move already
Knight to e4 so it's important that I
now get out of the line of fire Queen a4
it's also just in general a good idea
right I'm up material so let's get the
most dangerous piece off the board
Queen exchange
and yep there should be three I should
have gone with that I give something up
here the bishops so yeah I should just
play Bishop to b3 and then what is there
rook e8 Bishop f4 real smooth okay I
don't know why I didn't see Bishop to b3
give up the bishop hair what more was
missed around here just a slight pull
not quite a full pond and by any means
mr. dark square Bishop is very strong
back what tactics might have been missed
it's even ish rook f3 yeah now it starts
to like me
King g7 was necessary can't allow that
rook to see f7 directly so they backed
up and this allowed me to push and how
could I have done better here G takes
right away yeah and takes like this with
Knight d5 right away improve the knight
position not the bishop position in this
case look at all the different jumping
points he's tied in really well with
this past pawn c7 c7 as we saw in the
game after I played Knight to e7 there
was maybe a second or two
you know black thought for a only a
second or two and reasoned he's just way
too good and annoying I have to give up
the exchange a night on e 7 is hitting
here threatening made even a night I
need 7 is threatening Knight g6 mate
combined with this Bishop on b3 yeah
so I should I should have improved the
knight position here d6 and Knight to d7
I was going I was going for this idea of
targeting this pawn with Bishop there
and then Bishop here and now I'm just
losing the
cuz of rook takes night oh man that
would have been painful they had a
tactical opportunity here
Bishop e4 it's only working this is only
tied together because I have the support
of the night he could be undermined he
could be taken out I think they're
enduring the game I was only looking at
oh the bishop could take the knight but
I would have this and this would be
working because now I'm threatening
discovered check threaten you to take a
piece with the discovered check looking
to remove a piece who is preventing this
ensuing fork and bought rook takes there
is no time for this because my rook
would be unprotected if I'm taking like
this well just losing down a piece I
take here they take there and one other
variation would be on this if I'm taking
with the pond now it's rook takes Bishop
and I'm fighting two bishops versus of
rook yikes they had an opportunity was
that the only opportunity rook takes
Knight maybe they'll slip this maybe
they minute rook takes Knight probably
not they're there to defend a5 Bishop d5
is holding it as around even and as soon
as the rook retreated this gave me a
second chance to get that Knight d5 move
in still holding as an advantage Knight
d5 97 it likes and yeah you have to give
that up threatening mate I think I only
get in the game I was only seeing it as
I fork but yeah so much more than that
they give it up and I just wanted to
simplify although this is giving the
advantage away you know I just wanted to
make it simple
rook g3 is better yeah tough to really
figure these things out I just wanted to
make it simple at that stage or at this
stage here in the ending the King
towards the center and well they just
blundered here at the end of the time
scramble but yeah
that h3 move I like I like this idea of
the h3 move prior to committing my deep
on its it's because of that e4 square
again not uh I don't want to allow that
night to jump into e4 so easily I want
to have the option of maybe kicking him
out and yeah it's it's sound here as
scary as it may look to be opposite the
bishop there isn't any good tactic here
against the white queen at this point
either because of the super valuable
dark square bishop that has given up
with that variation and yeah I should
have played Bishop to b3 here instead of
giving the bishop pair up and I'm just
holding on to a clear pawn okay well
anyhow I know is a fast one here that's
Rio but uh anyhow feel free to leave any
feedback in the comments section below
to this video as usual and I hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now take care bye
you